Adriene: Welcome to Crash Course Economics,
I’m Adriene Hill
Jacob: and I’m Jacob Clifford. Some of you
might be watching this video in school right
now, but even if you’re not, you’ve probably
spent a good chunk of your life getting educated.
Adriene: Nearly all countries require at least
some mandatory schooling and most of those
countries provide that education for free.
Jacob: But nothing is ever actually free.
There’s always an opportunity cost. The money
and resources that go into education might be used
to fund other social programs or bring down the debt.
Adriene: And if you go to college, the cost
is not just the tuition and books, it’s
also the income you could have earned by going
straight into the workforce.
Jacob: But is college even worth it? Well,
let's look at the economics of education.
[Theme Music]
Adriene: Why do governments spend billions
funding universal public education? Why not
just let profit seeking businesses handle it?
Many argue that if education was entirely privatized
it’s likely that some children would be excluded,
and that would make society, as a whole, worse off.
Education is a positive externality. Education
benefits individuals by helping them get a
job and earn more income, but it also benefits
society as these individuals create art, invent
cool stuff, cure diseases, and make interesting
conversation at parties. More education increases
productivity, GDP, and standards of living.
So, today we’re going to look at the education
system in the United States. We’re talking
about the US not only because we make Crash
Course in the US, but because education in
this country is going through a lot of changes.
This way, we get to talk about things like
education standards, vouchers, and student
debt.
Now, to be sure, there are places that do
things differently. For example, in the European
Union college costs a lot less than it does
in the US, or is even free.
In America, the government pays for primary
and secondary public education and heavily
subsidizes college. In 2015, the federal and
state governments will spend about 634 billion
dollars on primary and secondary education.
That’s an average of about 12,500 dollars
per student each year. Which is a lot of money.
And despite all that spending, the US has
some serious problems with its education system.
One of the biggest is inequality. Students
from low income families tend to have lower
math and reading test scores than those from
higher income families. African American,
Latino, and Native American students are much
more likely to drop out of high school than
their White or Asian counterparts.
Jacob: For some economists, the best way to
level the playing field is to focus on funding.
They argue that the government should pay
for early education programs, and provide
extra money for disadvantaged and
low-income students.
For others, the answer isn’t just about
more funding, it’s about having more competition.
Some economists support charter schools and
voucher programs that allow parents to pick
schools, or open enrollment among or within
school districts.
Now in theory, this forces all schools to
improve, or face losing their funding. Other
economists focus on the teachers, and argue that they
should be incentivized to improve student performance.
Each of these ideas have been implemented
in the US, with varying success. We have yet
to find the magic formula, but it’s clear
that the first step to improving equality
is to invest in primary and secondary education.
Now, what about higher education? Is that
a good investment? Well, keep in mind that
there are many reasons – not all of them
economic - to go to college, and to be educated
in general. People go to college because they
enjoy learning and want to know more. Or maybe
they want to put off getting a real job. But in economics,
we focus on financial benefits. So, is college worth it?
The fact is, college graduates, on average, earn more.
Economists call this the “College Wage Premium.”
Among 25-32 year-olds, college grads earn
an average of $45,000 vs $28,000 for those who only
have a high school diploma. Also, the unemployment
rate for college grads is pretty much always lower.
Right now, for people over 25 with a college degree,
unemployment is around 3%. Now, that's vs. around
5.4 percent for those with only a high-school
diploma. And it’s 8.6 percent for those who didn’t
finish high school. So bam – college pays
off, case closed.
Adriene: Well, not quite. The people who graduate
from college are NOT a randomly selected group.
First, it takes a modicum of intelligence
and dedication to even get into college. Second,
you have to receive a fairly good primary and secondary
education to be able to keep up with college work.
Third, the students who attend college are
more likely to come from well-off families
with educated parents who have the time and
energy to help encourage their success.
So when you compare college grads to those
with less education, you’re often comparing
people from advantaged backgrounds to people
without many of those advantages. The fact
that college graduates make more money isn’t
just about college. It’s also about life
circumstances. Let’s go to the Thought Bubble:
Jacob: Economists point out two main explanations
for why college graduates earn more. The first
is the “Human Capital” theory. The idea
is that going to college actually teaches
you skills that’ll help you get a higher
income job. The second theory is called “Signalling.”
This is the idea that some students have shown
they're smart and hard-working, but in a job interview,
EVERYONE is going to claim “Sure, I’m
smart and hard-working!” even applicants
who aren’t. So the talented applicants need
something else to validate their abilities
that can’t be faked by others. A college
degree sends a clear signal. "Look at me!
I graduated Summa, and I’ve got the notarized
transcripts to prove it!"
Many employers would prefer an applicant that
has an actual Harvard degree over one that
has an equivalent self-taught education. But
a college degree isn’t only about signaling
ability, we could accomplish that with a test
that would take one day and $100, rather than
4 years and potentially hundreds of thousands
of dollars. College degrees send other signals
about socio-economic status and background.
BOTH the human capital theory and the signalling
theory are compatible with the data: both
predict that college graduates would earn
more, which is what we see.
But economists have tried to figure out which
theory is correct. They have compared the
earnings of people who have earned 7 ½ semesters
worth of college credits but didn’t graduate,
to people who finished and got a degree. Both
groups received about the same amount of education,
so if the Human Capital theory is correct,
they should earn about the same amount of
money. If the Signalling theory is correct,
those with degrees should earn noticeably
more, and they do. But it’s a smaller gap
than you would find from just comparing high
school and college grads. It seems that both
theories apply.
Adriene: Thanks Thought Bubble. Okay, so we
know that there are significant financial
benefits to completing college. But what about
the costs? Going to college can be really
expensive. Often more than most families can
afford. In the US, students have over 1 trillion
dollars of debt. That’s more than Americans
owe on their cars or their credit cards!
More students are attending college than ever,
and more of those students are paying for
at least part of their education with loans.
In 2012, almost 70 percent of students took
out loans to pay for tuition, and the median
amount they borrowed was around 27,000 dollars.
By comparison, in 1993, the median amount
students borrowed was around 12,500 dollars.
And that’s just the median. So even if some
of the hand-wringing over the total amount
of student debt is overblown, the average
student really is taking on a larger burden.
So, this is all thanks to higher tuition,
right? Well, not exactly. At four-year public
universities, the average cost of tuition,
room and board has gone from $10,600 dollars
in 1994 to $18,900 in 2014, when you adjust
for inflation. The average tuition at comparable
private universities has risen from $26,500
to $42,400 during the same period.
But that rising tuition number is the “sticker
price” for college – in fact, most students
receive very substantial discounts. Students
from wealthy families, with not-so-great SAT
scores might pay that full sticker price,
but once you factor in cost reductions from
scholarships, fellowships, grants and other
sources, many students pay substantially less.
Once you adjust for discounting, the rise
in net tuition has been kind of modest.
So, why all the debt? Well, for-profit colleges
and universities might be contributing to this.
Students at these schools tend to take
on more debt than students at public schools
or private non-profits. It’s also possible
that student debt is rising because graduate
school enrollment is up. And grad students
borrow more than undergrads.
Another reason tuitions are increasing is
because the actual cost of running a college
is higher than a few decades ago. As some
schools compete for students and their money,
some of them build luxurious dorms, climbing
walls and gourmet dining to attract revenue.
Another possibility is that colleges now employ more
administrators and pay them a whole bunch of money.
Jacob: So, in cold, hard, merciless dollars,
does it make sense to spend – or borrow
- a bunch of money on a college degree? Well,
it depends a lot on the degree you get, but
on average the answer is, yes -- as long as
you finish!
Many of the worst student-debt horror stories
involve students who racked up large debt,
but were unable to finish college. And that’s
surprisingly common: Every year in the US,
60% of high-school graduates enroll in college,
but only a little over half actually graduate
within 6 years. That’s right: only half.
But what about students that don’t have
the means or the inclination to go to a four-year
university? Are they doomed to live in squalor?
Well, no, but again better money can be found
in careers that require specific training
and skills, which can be learned through a
community college or through an apprenticeship.
The average car mechanic earns $40,000 a year;
the average plumber earns $50,000; and the average
electrician $55,000. And as more young people
opt to go to college and as older people in these careers
retire, most economists expect these wages to rise.
So what is the final conclusion? Is college
even worth it? Well, I guess in the end, we
have to say, it depends. It depends on where
you go to school; how much you pay for your degree;
and it depends on what degree you get.
And, of course, on what you want to do with your life.
Adriene: Education isn’t just another thing
that you buy. It isn’t only about individual
gain. There’s a social aspect, too. We want
everyone to have access to quality education
because having an educated populace benefits
all of us. Education can also be a powerful
tool when it comes to reducing poverty and
addressing income inequality, and we're gonna
talk about that next time. Thanks for watching!
Jacob: Thanks for watching Crash Course Economics.
It was made with the help of all these nice people.
You can help keep Crash Course free,
for everyone forever by supporting the show
at Patreon. Patreon is a voluntary subscription
service where you can support the show with
a monthly contribution. Thanks for watching!
DFTBA.